una gira clave y necesaria en un
contexto económico complejo el
presidente cubano fue recibido en China
por su homólogo en la última parada de
Super diplo internacional
Beijing es uno de los principales
aliados de La Habana por lo que la
visita Tuvo una connotación
principalmente económica y simbólica el
señor presidente es el primer jefe de
estado de los países de América Latina y
el Caribe que visita china después del
vigésimo Congreso Nacional del partido
comunista Chino lo que refleja la
especial relación amistosa entre las dos
naciones
anteriormente el jefe de estado caribeño
sostuvo un encuentro en Turquía con el
presidente receptalle
evaluamos las oportunidades para
desarrollar la cooperación existente en
Campos como la energía el turismo la
construcción la agricultura el
desarrollo la salud y el medio ambiente
Argelia y Rusia también fueron parte del
trayecto la cancelación de los servicios
de la deuda de laplazamiento de su pago
fue una de las decisiones más
importantes de su visita argel y el paso
por Rusia reforzó la unión de ambos
países en un frente común
la hacemos en un momento en que ambos
países ambas naciones tanto Rusia como
Cuba están sometidas
a sanciones injustas arbitrarias que
proceden y tienen su origen el mismo
enemigo el Imperio Yankee que ha
manipulado también a una parte
importante
un encuentro con varios empresarios
turcos antes de retornar a la Habana